Donc, Ézéchiel était un sacrificateur et il se retrouve déporté à Babylone.
Il est très abattu de cette situation et c'est dans cette situation que Dieu vient le trouver
et que Dieu l'établit comme sentinelle pour son peuple.
Donc, quand il dit sentinelle, c'est qu'Ézéchiel devait parler de la part de l'Éternel pour mettre en garde le peuple.
Ce que Dieu voulait dire, c'est que le jugement de Jérusalem était en train de commencer
et le peuple d'Israël ne se rendait pas compte.
Une partie avait été déportée, mais ils espéraient encore rentrer à Jérusalem.
Ils espéraient encore que Dieu, parce qu'ils connaissaient ce Dieu,
ils savaient ce que ce Dieu avait fait tout au long de leur histoire,
ils savaient que ce Dieu avait brisé la puissance des Égyptiens,
avait brisé la puissance de plusieurs nations, même la Syrie qui était alors une grande puissance.
Et ils espéraient donc que Dieu fasse la même chose avec Babylone
et qu'il puisse ensuite rentrer à Jérusalem.
Mais Dieu dit par la bouche d'Ézéchiel qu'il ne faut pas qu'ils espèrent rentrer à Jérusalem
parce que ce qui se passe, c'est que Dieu est en train de juger son peuple.
Et donc, qu'est-ce que Dieu va faire ?
Pour qu'il puisse comprendre, à un moment, Ézéchiel ne parle pas,
mais il agit par des signes.
C'est-à-dire, là, vous pouvez avoir le projecteur qui affiche,
il pouvait faire des choses comme ça,
mais là, il va plutôt, à un moment, il va se coucher, par exemple, sur un côté,
après, sur plusieurs jours, après, il se couche sur un autre côté, sur plusieurs jours.
Et le peuple le voyait, ils étaient en train de le voir faire des choses assez bizarres.
Ils le voyaient, par exemple, construire une sorte de mur
où il représentait le siège de Jérusalem.
Et nous arrivons, et donc, nous arrivons au chapitre 5.
Là aussi, c'est encore la même chose.
C'est-à-dire que Dieu va dire à un moment à Ézéchiel de prendre un rasoir,
de se raser la tête et la barbe.
Il faut savoir que c'était le commandement que Dieu ordonnait au sacrificateur.
Il était interdit, formellement, au sacrificateur de se raser entièrement la tête,
de se raser entièrement la barbe.
Donc, quand Dieu est en train de demander cela à Ézéchiel,
c'est pour qu'eux, ils comprennent.
C'est-à-dire que ceux qui sont autour d'Ézéchiel,
quand ils vont voir que le sacrificateur,
qui est censé représenter la loi,
qui est censé montrer la loi,
est en train, justement, de se raser,
de faire des choses, ces choses,
ils vont s'interroger, ils vont se dire,
mais pourquoi Ézéchiel est en train de se raser la tête ?
Qu'est-ce qu'il veut nous dire par là ?
Et c'était dans ce sens que Dieu permettait qu'il le fasse.
Et donc, Dieu lui demande de se raser.
Et ensuite, quand il a fini de se raser,
il prend l'ensemble de sa chevelure,
de tout ce qu'il en reste,
il pèse dans une balance,
et il partage les cheveux.
Et donc, quand il faisait ça,
il y avait des gens qui le regardaient.
Alors, je ne sais pas si vous arrivez à vous mettre dans le contexte,
c'était assez bizarre.
Donc, à un moment de la journée, il va faire ça.
Il ne parle pas.
Il lui pose des questions, il ne parle pas.
Il fait juste le geste.
Il prend, il met, il partage les cheveux.
Mais plus tard, il va avoir l'occasion de leur expliquer.
Et lorsqu'il fait ça,
donc Dieu lui dit,
tu prends un tiers des cheveux,
tu les brûles dans le feu,
au milieu de la ville.
Et ça, c'était pour symboliser,
lorsque Babylone allait vraiment prendre,
maintenant, possession de Jérusalem,
ils allaient attaquer par le feu.
Il y allait avoir des incendies.
Il y allait avoir le feu.
Certains allaient mourir par l'épée et par le feu.
Donc, ça, c'était une partie de ses cheveux.
C'était pour symboliser ça.
Donc, la tête, dans le symbole,
la tête d'Ézéchiel symbolisait Jérusalem.
Et donc, Jérusalem,
la parure dont Jérusalem avait été parée,
Dieu allait enlever cette parure.
Donc, Ézéchiel se rase pour montrer
que Jérusalem va être rasée,
va être détruite.
Un autre tiers des cheveux
devait être frappé
avec le rasoir autour de la ville.
Et donc, là, ça parlait de ceux
qui allaient fuir la ville,
mais qui, malgré tout,
allaient être frappés par les Babyloniens.
Et d'ailleurs, dans cette situation,
vous avez, quand vous lisez le livre de Jérémie,
vous avez le roi même,
Cédécias,
qui était à l'époque
le roi que Nebuchadnezzar avait placé.
Mais il va se rebeller.
Et lorsque Nebuchadnezzar fait le siège,
Cédécias essaye de fuir la nuit.
Il fuit la ville,
il fuit Jérusalem,
mais il se fait rattraper par les Babyloniens.
Donc, c'est un exemple.
Et enfin, le dernier tiers
est dispersé au vent.
Et malgré ça,
Dieu tire l'épée derrière eux.
Et donc, ce dernier tiers,
c'était pour parler
de ceux qui allaient même fuir dans les nations.
Ils allaient fuir dans les nations,
mais même là,
Dieu allait les poursuivre.
C'est-à-dire, ils allaient fuir en Égypte,
mais Dieu allait les poursuivre en Égypte.
La guerre allait les poursuivre en Égypte.
Il y a même une dernière catégorie.
Il dit,
tu en prendras une petite quantité.
Donc là, je vous résume
ce que nous avons vu
sur les quatre premiers versets du chapitre 5.
Il dit,
tu en prendras une petite quantité
que tu serras dans les bords de ton vêtement.
Et de cela,
tu en prendras encore quelques-uns
que tu jetteras au feu
et que tu brûleras dans le feu.
Et ce qui est étonnant,
c'est que tout ce que Ézéchiel est en train de décrire,
c'est comme ça que les choses se sont accomplies.
C'est-à-dire,
quand il parle même de ce reste de cheveux
qu'il va mettre dans un vêtement,
mais qui, malgré tout,
il va se jeter au feu,
c'est pour parler à un moment
qu'il y a des cheveux
dont il voulait prendre soin.
C'est-à-dire que même lorsque
les Babyloniens vont prendre Jérusalem,
ils vont laisser un reste
de juifs sur le territoire.
mais même parmi ce reste,
il y en a qui vont se rebeller
et le feu va venir sur eux.
C'est-à-dire qu'ils vont se rebeller,
ils vont tuer le gouverneur
que les Babyloniens avaient établi
et ils vont s'enfuir en Égypte.
Et même là, en Égypte,
Dieu va les poursuivre en Égypte.
Et donc, là,
il parlait aussi de ce reste-là.
Et là, nous venons,
nous venons donc à ce que nous avions dit
la semaine dernière,
à partir du verset 5.
À un moment, donc, il dit à un moment,
je parle de cette Jérusalem.
Donc, quand il parle du crâne d'Ézéchiel,
il dit, je parle de cette Jérusalem
que j'avais placée au milieu des nations.
C'est-à-dire qu'il avait placé Jérusalem
au cœur.
C'est-à-dire, quand vous étudiez l'histoire,
vous voyez que Jérusalem était dans une des régions
où l'histoire s'est écrite.
Et il avait placé Jérusalem
pour que Jérusalem soit en train d'enseigner
les lois de Dieu,
les ordonnances de Dieu.
Mais Jérusalem ne l'a pas fait.
Au contraire, ils se sont rebellés.
Ils n'ont pas suivi les ordonnances de Dieu.
Ils ont méprisé la parole de Dieu.
Ils ont rajouté, enlevé des choses
à la parole de Dieu.
Et à cause de ça,
le jugement de Dieu est venu sur eux.
Et ce jugement, aujourd'hui,
nous allons, comme je disais,
nous allons rentrer un peu plus en détail
sur les aspects de ce jugement.
Un moment de voir pourquoi il y a eu ce jugement.
Et je ne sais pas, peut-être que pour ceux
qui suivent depuis un moment les prédications
que nous faisons sur Ézéchiel,
c'est vrai que ça peut être très difficile
à comprendre.
Ça peut être très difficile aussi à accepter
quand nous avons une certaine idée
de la nature de qui est Dieu.
mais au fur et à mesure que nous sommes en train de parcourir,
en tout cas pour moi, au fur et à mesure que je suis en train
de parcourir,
je vois quelque chose d'encourageant,
je vois quelque chose de bénéfique pour nous
au travers de ce livre.
La vérité que nous avons,
donc, dans le passage que notre soeur,
dans l'ensemble des versets que notre soeur a pu nous lire,
la vérité que nous voyons là-dessus,
lorsque Dieu parle des jugements qu'il accomplit,
c'est que nous voyons au moment que Dieu est un Dieu jaloux.
Les autres nations avaient la possibilité,
dans les autres nations,
elles adoraient tous les dieux,
c'est-à-dire que si elles allaient dans une autre nation
et voyaient les dieux de cette nation,
ils pouvaient choisir de prendre ce Dieu,
de l'amener dans leur nation
et de le placer aussi dans le Panthéon.
Mais au niveau d'Israël,
Israël, Dieu les avait déjà avertis,
il était un Dieu unique
et il ne voulait pas qu'il y ait d'autres dieux
qui soient à côté de lui.
Et donc, c'est ce qu'il enseigne à Israël
au travers du jugement,
c'est que Dieu est un Dieu jaloux
qui ne partage pas sa gloire.
Et lorsqu'il parle dans sa fureur,
donc c'est les passages que nous avons lus,
dans sa fureur,
il exécute ses jugements comme Israël
ne l'avait jamais vécu.
Si vous avez l'occasion de lire l'Ancien Testament,
vous verrez que toute la description
que Dieu va faire des jugements
qui vont s'abattre sur Jérusalem,
toute la description faite par Esaïe,
par Jérémie, par Ézéchiel,
même par les autres prophètes,
nous allons voir au moment
que Jérusalem n'avait jamais, jamais vécu cela.
Mais, ce qui est étonnant,
lorsque nous lisons même un passage,
ou nous lisons des passages
où Dieu dit même que
les pères vont dévorer des enfants,
les enfants vont dévorer les pères,
la Bible nous montre un moment
qu'il le faisait pour le bien d'Israël.
C'est assez bizarre à comprendre,
mais il le faisait pour le bien d'Israël,
et il le faisait pour que ce soit un avertissement
pour les nations qui étaient tout autour.
Donc, les jugements,
c'est pour ça que Dieu annonce
ces jugements des siècles avant.
Quand nous lisons déjà la parole,
nous avons vu la semaine dernière
que si nous lisons Deutéronome et Lévitique,
nous voyons au moment
que lorsque Israël établit l'alliance avec Dieu,
il les avertit au moment
que si vous vous détournez
de mes lois et de mes commandements,
voici ce qui vous arrivera.
Et Israël dit Amen.
On va choisir de suivre l'Éternel,
on n'ira pas à droite ni à gauche.
Mais pourtant, c'est ce qu'ils ont fait.
Et donc, comme ils n'ont pas respecté cette alliance,
comme ils n'ont pas respecté cette alliance,
le jugement s'abat.
Et ce jugement, c'est un jugement qui va être naturel
par les éléments de la nature.
C'est un jugement qui va être humain.
C'est un jugement qui va être répété.
Parce que vous savez qu'à un moment,
s'il y a une chose qui arrive,
comme ça, on peut dire que c'est le hasard.
On se dit que c'est arrivé une fois.
Comme dirait quelqu'un,
si aujourd'hui je sors dans la rue,
je croise un lion,
ça peut être normal.
Il s'est échappé du zoo,
il y a un problème.
Mais si lundi,
je croise encore un lion dans la rue,
là, on ne sait plus.
Si vendredi,
je croise encore un lion dans la rue,
là, il y a quelque chose qui n'est plus naturel.
Il y a un problème.
Et là, c'est la même chose.
C'est-à-dire que dans ce que Dieu est en train de faire,
de ces jugements qui sont répétés,
c'était pour qu'Israël comprenne
que ce n'était pas le fruit du hasard.
Il n'allait pas dire à un moment,
ces choses nous sont arrivées par hasard.
Non.
Ce sont des jugements qui sont établis
parce qu'ils ont été annoncés des siècles avant même
par les prophètes.
Et tous ceux,
et quand ces jugements vont arriver,
tous ceux qui ont connu,
qui verront ces jugements vont se dire,
un moment,
qui peut tenir devant le Dieu d'Israël
lorsqu'il est en colère
à cause du péché ?
C'est-à-dire que les nations qui sont autour
sauront un moment
que Dieu a jugé son peuple
parce qu'ils se sont détournés de leur Dieu.
Et le dernier passage,
quand nous avons lu à la fin du verset 17,
il dit,
c'est moi l'éternel qui parle.
C'est un peu comme s'il était en train de signer.
Il est en train de dire
que c'est lui-même
qui va travailler au jugement d'Israël.
C'est lui-même qui va être rigoureux,
qui va être violent
pour s'assurer que le jugement serve d'exemple
et d'avertissement pour les nations.
Et donc,
le premier point que nous allons voir,
c'est au verset 8.
C'est pour ça que je vous disais,
on va beaucoup plus se concentrer
sur trois versets aujourd'hui.
C'est pratiquement les versets 8 à 10.
Mais nous avons lu le reste aussi
parce que nous allons,
le verset 8, par exemple,
il y a des éléments
vers le verset 15 ou 13
qui les expliquent mieux.
Donc, verset 8,
où nous voyons à un moment
que Dieu lui-même va œuvrer
pour punir Jérusalem,
il dit, verset 8,
« À cause de cela,
ainsi parle le Seigneur l'Éternel,
voici, j'en veux à toi,
voici, j'en veux à toi. »
Pendant des siècles,
et là où nous voyons
que c'est quelque chose
qui était déjà surnaturel,
c'est-à-dire que
pendant des siècles,
Israël était un petit royaume.
C'était un petit royaume.
Et quand nous connaissons
l'histoire de cette région,
il n'était pas normal
qu'un petit royaume
comme celui d'Israël
puisse prospérer,
perdurer pendant autant de siècles.
Et même pendant tout le temps,
c'est-à-dire depuis Moïse
jusqu'à Ézéchiel,
nous allons remarquer un moment
que plusieurs grands empires
ont essayé d'envahir
le territoire d'Israël,
mais n'ont jamais réussi.
Dieu a donné des limites
à Israël à ne pas dépasser.
Et d'ailleurs,
les limites à un moment
ont été pratiquement atteintes
par David et Salomon.
Mais après,
lorsqu'il y a eu la scission,
ça a changé.
Mais on voit un moment
que Dieu a protégé Israël
pendant des siècles.
Il l'a défendu,
il l'a sauvé,
même au moyen de miracles.
Parce que quand nous lisons
l'histoire avec Sénachérib,
le roi assyrien,
où il y a près de 185 000 soldats
assyriens qui vont être tués
par un seul ange de l'éternel,
nous voyons un moment
que là,
la main de Dieu
s'est abattée même
sur des grandes nations
pour protéger Israël.
Et donc,
pendant des siècles,
Israël est rentré
dans une certaine confiance
parce que pour eux,
rien ne pouvait leur arriver.
Dieu avait promis
qu'il allait siéger
au milieu d'Israël
et donc rien ne pouvait leur arriver.
Et donc,
à un moment,
ils ont considéré aussi
qu'ils pouvaient aussi pécher
et que rien ne pouvait leur arriver.
Et ce qui est même intéressant,
si vous vous souvenez,
lorsque nous avons parlé des jours
où Ézéchiel se penchait
d'un côté comme d'un autre,
il y a certains jours
qui correspondaient,
il y a à peu près 300 jours
pour le royaume du Nord.
Il devait faire 300 jours
couchés d'un côté
pour le royaume du Nord.
Et nous voyons qu'à un moment,
les 300 jours correspondaient
à à peu près,
300 et quelques,
je ne sais plus
si c'est 390 ou autre,
mais ces 300 jours
correspondaient
à des années.
Et donc,
pendant des années,
il est en train de demander pardon
pour presque 3 siècles
de péché
du royaume du Nord.
Mais lorsque nous arrivons
au royaume du Sud,
c'est-à-dire le royaume du Juda,
qui va rester
et qui va même être attaqué
par Babylone,
on remarque qu'à un moment,
il ne va prendre que 40 jours.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que,
même quand il arriva à Israël
de péché,
dès qu'ils revenaient à Dieu,
qu'ils demandaient pardon
à leur péché,
Dieu les restaurait.
Le territoire qu'ils avaient perdu
à cause du fait
qu'ils s'étaient détournés
de l'éternel,
Dieu permettait
qu'ils puissent vaincre
leurs ennemis
et qu'ils puissent récupérer.
Donc,
ils étaient rentrés
dans une sorte de confiance
où ils se disaient
à un moment,
rien ne peut nous arriver
parce que Dieu
est sur cette terre.
Et voilà pourquoi
Ézéchiel était très dépassé
lorsqu'il arrive à Babylone,
qu'il était très découragé
parce que pour lui,
il y avait quelque chose
qui s'était brisé.
C'est-à-dire que Dieu avait promis
qu'il allait toujours être avec eux,
que rien ne pouvait arriver
à Jérusalem,
mais là,
il se retrouvait à Babylone.
Et donc,
dès qu'Israël a péché,
à un moment,
la patience de Dieu
est en train d'arriver
à sa limite.
Et là,
Dieu dit maintenant,
j'en veux,
je t'en veux,
j'en veux à toi.
Et là,
c'est dans ce sens
où Dieu prend son titre
d'éternel des armées.
Quand on parle de Dieu
comme l'éternel des armées,
on parle de celui
qui commande
jusqu'au plus petit atome
de l'univers.
On parle de celui
qui commande
sur toutes les armées des cieux,
les armées qui sont sur la terre,
sur la terre,
toutes les armées lui sont soumises.
Et la parole de Dieu
nous dit à un moment
que si Dieu
est contre nous,
ce qu'il nous montre,
et c'était le cas maintenant
d'Israël,
quand il dit,
j'en veux à toi,
c'est que maintenant
qu'il était contre Israël,
c'est même toute la création
de Dieu
qui allait être contre Israël.
il n'y a rien
qui allait pouvoir faire.
Et quand nous lisons
certains passages,
notamment dans Jérémie,
je vous avais parlé
du rasoir,
il y a une expression
dans le mot,
dans les versions originales,
quand on parle,
il dit,
fils de l'homme,
prends un instrument tranchant
au verset 5.
On a un,
au chapitre,
au verset 1
du chapitre 5,
on a cette expression
de rasoir de louage,
c'est-à-dire,
va prendre le rasoir du barbier,
va louer le rasoir du barbier
pour l'utiliser.
Et donc là,
Dieu est en train
de montrer un moment
que derrière l'armée babylonienne,
c'est Dieu qui était là.
C'est-à-dire que quand il parle
d'utiliser le rasoir du barbier,
ça veut dire un moment
que Dieu pouvait choisir
soit les Assyriens,
sur une époque,
soit les Babyloniens,
mais là,
Dieu avait décidé
que la nation
qui allait punir
Israël
allait être Babylone.
Et ce qu'il est en train
de leur dire un moment,
il leur montre un moment
que non seulement
il avait parlé contre eux
par les prophètes,
mais maintenant,
il allait exécuter
ses jugements.
Il allait exécuter
Les jugements de Dieu,
un moment,
quand ils arrivaient,
ça pouvait toucher une partie,
mais ça n'avait jamais
touché le cœur,
c'est-à-dire,
même Jérusalem
n'avait jamais été envahie.
Et là,
Dieu dit à un moment
que non seulement
toute la ville sera prise,
mais même les frontières
du pays,
les entrailles du pays,
tout le pays sera pris.
Une situation
qu'il n'avait jamais vécue.
Et quand nous lisons
la parole,
depuis Lévitique
et Deutéronome,
nous voyons que ce sont
des choses sur lesquelles
Dieu les avait mis en garde.
Et là,
nous voyons encore
la patience de Dieu.
Pendant des siècles,
Dieu parle au travers
des prophètes,
il annonce ses jugements,
mais Israël refuse d'écouter
parce qu'Israël est rentré
dans une certaine confiance,
Israël est rentré
dans une certaine habitude
de péché.
Mais là,
Dieu dit à un moment
qu'il sera celui
qui va exécuter.
C'est lui,
derrière ce jugement
de Babylone,
c'est lui qui sera
en train de juger
parce qu'Israël
ne l'a pas honoré.
Et voilà pourquoi
ceux qui avaient,
nous étions en train
de parler,
la semaine dernière,
on parlait
de l'importance
du souvenir.
Parce qu'il y en avait,
lorsque ces choses
sont en train
de s'abattre sur eux,
ils étaient étonnés.
Ils se demandaient
pourquoi la main de Dieu
était sur le peuple,
était sur Israël.
Certains étaient étonnés.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'il n'y avait pas
eu cette transmission.
Il n'y avait pas eu
cette transmission de mémoire.
Mais certains
ne vont pas être étonnés.
Et nous parlions
dans ce sens aussi
de l'importance
d'exhorter nos enfants.
Pourquoi nous devons
nous assurer
que même quand nos enfants
ne sont pas encore convertis,
nous soyons en train
de leur enseigner
la parole de Dieu,
de leur expliquer
la parole de Dieu.
Même s'ils ne la comprennent
pas entièrement,
c'est important
de leur expliquer,
de leur faire comprendre
toutes ces choses
qui peuvent être difficiles.
Je me souviens,
quand j'étais un peu plus petit,
j'aurais aimé souvent
jouer avec les enfants,
j'aurais aimé jouer
avec les enfants
quand les enfants jouaient
souvent à l'arrière-cours
pendant le culte,
surtout quand j'étais en Afrique,
au Congo.
Mais ma mère,
quand elle nous emmenait
au culte,
je crois que j'avais
peut-être 7 ou 8 ans,
mon petit frère
en avait 5 ou 6,
et elle nous obligeait
à écouter la prédication.
On ne comprenait rien,
on regardait souvent
les enfants derrière
qui étaient en train de jouer,
on avait envie
de les rejoindre.
Moi, on n'arrivait pas.
mais la bénédiction
que nous avons eue
à un moment,
c'est que pratiquement
toutes ces histoires,
bon, bien sûr,
il y a des profondeurs
de l'évangile
qui ne nous étaient pas expliquées,
mais toutes ces histoires,
on en avait déjà conscience.
Ce sont des choses
qu'on nous avait déjà expliquées
et c'est très important
dans ce sens-là.
Et pourquoi c'est important ?
Parce que certains
n'ont pas compris
quand le jugement
s'abat sur eux.
Par contre,
d'autres vont le comprendre.
Lorsque Daniel
arrive à Babylone,
Daniel va intercéder.
Daniel a compris
pourquoi ces jugements
s'abattent.
Et quand vous regardez
les prières d'intercession
de Daniel
et même de plusieurs autres
qui vont intercéder,
ils vont intercéder en disant
« Dieu, pardonne-nous
car nous avons péché.
Nos pères ont péché,
nous avons péché
et voilà pourquoi
ces choses nous sont arrivées. »
Parce qu'il y avait eu
la transmission
de la mémoire
et ils avaient compris
à un moment
que maintenant,
pour obtenir le pardon de Dieu,
il fallait qu'ils intercèdent.
Mais d'autres ne l'avaient pas
et ils étaient dans l'espoir
de pouvoir rentrer
à Jérusalem.
Ils n'avaient pas compris
ce que Dieu
était en train de faire.
Et s'ils ne comprennent pas,
si nous ne comprenons pas
ce que Dieu
est en train de faire,
il n'y a pas aussi
de possibilité
à un moment
quand les choses nous arrivent,
il n'y aura pas
de possibilité de repentance.
Parce qu'à un moment,
si nous sommes en train
de dire « Mais Seigneur,
pourquoi tu permets
que ces choses m'arrivent
et que nous n'arrivions pas
à être dans une introspection
pour nous dire un moment
qu'est-ce qu'il peut faire ? »
Dieu peut permettre
que certaines choses nous arrivent
sans que nous ayons péché
pour nous permettre
de nous former,
de nous forger.
Mais il peut aussi permettre
que certaines choses nous arrivent
parce que nous avons péché.
Et nous devons trouver
une bénédiction du fait
de vivre les conséquences
de nos péchés
parce que nous savons
que Dieu ne nous punit jamais
à la hauteur
de ce que nous méritons.
mais nous devons être reconnaissants
et nous dire un moment
« Seigneur,
si ces choses m'arrivent aussi,
il peut y avoir un moment
que ce soit parce que j'ai péché
et alors je saurai aussi
demander pardon. »
Mais certains n'ont pas pu
le comprendre.
Ils n'ont pas compris
mais Dieu donne beaucoup
d'éléments pour qu'ils comprennent
à un moment que les jugements
qui sont en train de s'abattre
ne sont pas le fruit du hasard.
Les jugements qui sont
en train de s'abattre
ne sont pas le fruit
de la puissance
de Nebuchadnezzar
ou de la puissance babylonienne.
Non.
C'est Dieu qui est en train
de permettre
que Babylone
puisse les vaincre.
Et là,
nous venons même
ça nous amène
sur le deuxième point
où on voit un moment
que ces punitions
proviennent
du fait que Dieu
est mécontent.
C'est-à-dire que Dieu
n'a pas prouvé
la conduite d'Israël
donc il est en train
de les punir.
Verset 8 toujours
il dit
et j'exécuterai
mes jugements
au milieu de toi
sous les yeux
des nations.
Et verset 15
là il explique
un peu plus ça
c'est toujours en lien
avec le verset 8
Tu seras un sujet
d'opprobre et de honte
un exemple
et un objet d'effroi
pour les nations
qui t'entourent
quand j'exécuterai
contre toi
mes jugements
avec colère
avec fureur
et par des châtiments
rigoureux
c'est moi l'éternel
qui parle.
Quand nous lisons
tout au long de la Bible
quand nous lisons la Bible
nous voyons que
la parole de Dieu
nous montre un Dieu
notre Dieu
est un Dieu
qui est patient
notre Dieu
est un Dieu
qui est miséricordieux
mais là
Dieu utilise
des expressions
d'une façon humaine
parce que quand Dieu
est en train de dire
je vais exécuter
mes jugements
avec colère
avec fureur
par des châtiments
rigoureux
il n'est pas en train
de parler
de notre fureur humaine
parce que nous
notre fureur humaine
lorsque nous nous mettons
en fureur
en colère
souvent nous allons être
dans un excès
de colère
un excès de fureur
nous allons même pécher
par moments
mais là
Dieu n'est pas en train
de pécher
mais il y a
un aspect anthropomorphique
où il est en train
de prendre des expressions
pour que nous comprenions
parce que si je croise
quelqu'un
qui est en colère
parce que je peux
croiser quelqu'un
qui est un peu
un peu fâché
je lui ai marché
sur le pied
il me dit
bon c'est pas un problème
mais je peux croiser
quelqu'un
à qui je marche
sur le pied
et là il se met
dans une colère noire
et là je vais voir
deux choses différentes
je vais même avoir peur
si je vois quelqu'un
qui est en train
de s'emporter
et c'est dans ce sens
où Dieu est en train
de parler
il dit avec colère
avec fureur
pour que nous soyons
en train de réaliser
combien sa colère
est grande
peut-être que
Israël ne l'avait pas
réalisé pendant
plusieurs siècles
où ils ont péché
ils ont répété le péché
et ils sont un peu
rentrés dans une certaine
habitude
où ils se sont dit
à un moment
de toute façon
Dieu nous restaurera
mais là Dieu est en train
de dire
il y a une colère
il y a une fureur
que vous n'avez jamais vue
qui va s'abattre
sur vous
et il est en train
d'exprimer
le fait que
quelque part
c'est quelque chose
qui touchait
à sa sainteté
c'est quelque chose
qui touchait
à sa justice
et comme l'a dit
notre frère
Christian tout à l'heure
Dieu ne laisse pas
le péché impuni
et il est en train
de montrer
que ce que
Israël avait fait
était une offense
profonde
c'était quelque chose
qu'il avait
profondément affecté
et c'est quelque chose
de très mauvais
qui l'a mené
à de tels ressentiments
parce que la parole
de Dieu nous dit
à un moment
que notre Dieu
ne change pas
il n'y a pas en lui
d'ombre ni de variation
mais dans ce qu'il est
en train d'exprimer
il est en train d'exprimer
une sainte colère
une sainte fureur
et le verset 13
là
j'ai
une autre verset
il dit
j'assouvirai ainsi
ma colère
et je ferai reposer
ma fureur sur eux
je me donnerai satisfaction
et ils sauront
que moi l'éternel
j'ai parlé dans ma colère
en répondant sur eux
ma fureur
ça c'est une autre version
de ce que nous venons
de lire
Israël avait
attristé Dieu
ils avaient déshonoré Dieu
parce que Dieu
les avait établis
il dit
je t'avais établi
au milieu des nations
il avait établi Israël
pour qu'Israël
soit une sorte de lumière
c'est à dire
qu'au milieu
de ces nations païennes
qui étaient dans les ténèbres
Israël devait briller
apporter la lumière
au travers de leur respect
des lois
et des ordonnances
de Dieu
mais Israël ne l'a pas fait
et donc Dieu
avait été déshonoré
parce que
imaginez un moment
si vous dites par exemple
voici mon fils
vous pouvez avoir
toute confiance en lui
il est vraiment sage
il est vraiment sérieux
et lorsque ces personnes
se tournent vers votre fils
il fait n'importe quoi
et là vous allez être déshonoré
vous allez vous dire
un moment
là il est en train
de me mettre la honte
comme on dit
dans nos expressions
il me met la honte
et là c'était dans ce même sens
c'est à dire que
Dieu avait été déshonoré
parce qu'il voulait
que les nations
se tournent vers Israël
pour voir la sagesse
que Dieu avait donnée
à Israël
au travers de ces lois
et on voit un moment
que Dieu l'a fait
au travers
pendant le règne de David
le règne de Salomon
une partie du règne de Salomon
quand il va avoir
son cœur tout entier
vers Dieu
nous voyons que
Dieu manifeste cette sagesse
où il y a même des nations
plusieurs nations
qui viennent
à Jérusalem
pour apprendre
du peuple
hébreu
mais là
Israël avait attristé Dieu
ils avaient déshonoré
par le péché
et c'est quelque chose
de drôle à voir
mais Dieu
allait être consolé
par la destruction
parce que Dieu
ne laisse pas
le péché impuni
voilà ce que
Esaïe 26
nous rappelle
à ce sujet
Esaïe 26
verset 10
nous avons souvent
cette impression
et c'est pour ça
que je parlais
de voir comme une grâce
le fait que Dieu
puisse nous corriger
de voir comme une grâce
quand j'étais un peu plus jeune
souvent j'étais
j'étais affecté
de voir
à un moment
que certains jeunes
pouvaient vivre
délibérément
dans le péché
et moi
dès qu'il m'arrivait
de peut-être
faire quelque chose
quelque chose
qui n'était pas correct
je voyais
comment ma conscience
était dérangée
et je me disais
un moment
mais pourquoi
les autres
leur conscience
n'est pas aussi dérangée
pourquoi
je dois toujours
être corrigé par Dieu
et souvent
même quand je lisais
la Bible
et je le vois maintenant
comme une bénédiction
chaque fois que je lis
la Bible
pour méditer
le Seigneur
me reprend toujours
ce quelque chose
il y a toujours
une correction
que Dieu m'apporte
mais vous voyez
c'est une correction
qui fait du bien
à notre cœur
vous ne ressortez pas
d'une méditation
de la parole de Dieu
où vous avez été
corrigé par Dieu
en étant abattu
au contraire
vous voyez
qu'il y a quelque chose
de tordu dans votre vie
que Dieu a redressé
par la parole
et vous êtes fortifié
vous êtes encouragé
et c'est après
que j'ai compris
la bénédiction
que nous pouvons avoir
que nous apprenions
la justice
par la correction de Dieu
mais nous ne devons pas
croire un moment
que parce que certains
sont en train de prospérer
en faisant ce qu'ils veulent
en allant dans le péché
comme ils veulent
de croire un moment
que Dieu
ne rendra pas justice
le problème
de l'être humain
et c'est même dans ce sens
où nous devons par exemple
voir des livres
comme Ézéchiel
si nous cherchons
à comprendre Ézéchiel
à l'instant même
nous allons trouver
que c'est un Dieu
qui est injuste
nous allons trouver
que c'est un Dieu
qui est dur
mais si nous comprenons
nous lisons le livre
d'Ézéchiel
à la lumière
de l'Ancien Testament
nous allons trouver
que notre Dieu
est un Dieu
miséricordieux
et juste
et nous allons aussi
comprendre un moment
que notre Dieu
même si nous avons
l'impression
que le méchant
prospère
sans justice
nous savons un moment
que Dieu
rendra toujours la justice
parce que Dieu
ne laisse pas le péché impuni
un moment
même sur des générations
il ne laissera pas
le péché impuni
sur plusieurs générations
donc Israël
avait attristé
mais Israël
mais Dieu
Dieu avait attristé
Dieu et déshonoré
Dieu par leur péché
mais Dieu
allait être consolé
par la destruction
de Jérusalem
il n'allait pas faire
grâce aux méchants
il allait leur apprendre
la justice
parce que Israël
s'était livré au mal
dans le pays de la droiture
il n'avait pas eu égard
à la majesté de Dieu
dans la situation
où nous sommes
le livre d'Ézéchiel
est un livre très difficile
à lire tout au début
parce qu'il nous parle
de cet accomplissement
du jugement
sur Israël
l'accomplissement
du jugement
sur les nations
même les nations
même cette nation
que Dieu a utilisée
pour juger Israël
sera plus tard jugée
et la faveur de Dieu
c'est que là maintenant
la lutte
entre la miséricorde
et le jugement
est terminé
maintenant
c'est le jugement de Dieu
qui prend le pas
sur la miséricorde
Dieu a été miséricordieux
envers Israël
pendant plusieurs siècles
mais maintenant
ce qu'il est en train
de nous dire
qu'est-ce qu'il nous dit
au verset 11
c'est pourquoi
verset 11
à la fin
la seconde partie
moi aussi
je retirerai mon oeil
et mon oeil
sera sans pitié
moi aussi
je n'aurai point
de miséricorde
c'est très difficile
mais sur l'instant
Dieu décide
d'appliquer
son jugement
là-dessus
quand nous lisons
plusieurs passages
de la Bible
nous allons voir
à un moment
que la compassion
de Dieu
permet que le jugement
soit différé
c'est-à-dire
plusieurs fois
nous allons voir
que Dieu
aurait dû juger
une nation
aurait même dû juger
Israël
aurait dû juger
des personnes
mais à un moment
à cause de sa compassion
il va différer
le jugement
d'ailleurs
c'était même le cas
de Jérusalem
à un moment
le jugement
a failli arriver
plus tôt
mais lorsque
Ézéchias
va honorer
le Seigneur
par rapport
à sa vie
Dieu lui rappelle
un moment
que ces choses
n'arriveront pas
de son vivant
il y a plusieurs
à qui il va rappeler
un moment
qu'à cause du fait
qu'ils ont servi
Dieu avec fidélité
ces choses
n'arriveront pas
de leur vivant
donc Dieu
diffère même
le jugement
ce jugement
qui aurait dû s'abattre
il va le différer
il va même
le raccourcir
mais là
nous sommes dans
une situation
qui est assez
exceptionnelle
Dieu parle
d'un jugement
sans miséricorde
il parle d'un jugement
qui va être
impitoyable
et si vous lisez
Ézéchiel
vous lisez
Jérémie
et c'est même
pour ça que
là encore
si vous lisez
le livre de Jérémie
c'est extraordinaire
de voir comment
tout au long
du livre de Jérémie
ce que
Dieu est en train
de dire à Ézéchiel
Dieu le dit
à Jérémie
et Jérémie
va avertir le peuple
Jérémie va leur dire
vous voyez
cela va arriver
il leur dit
un moment
vous pensez
quand vous alliez
à l'Égypte
Babylone ne va pas arriver
mais je vous dis
que Babylone va vaincre
l'Égypte
et Babylone va arriver
c'est exactement
ce qui va arriver
et un moment
il leur dit
Babylone vous entoure
si vous ne vous rendez pas
il y aura la famine
il y aura
toutes ces calamités
que je vous annonce
vont arriver
si vous ne vous rendez pas
au roi de Babylone
ils ne vont pas l'écouter
et voilà pourquoi
c'est extraordinaire
parce que
lorsque Babylone
les Babyloniens
vont rentrer
et qu'ils vont prendre
Jérusalem
ils vont détruire Jérusalem
il y a une seule personne
à qui ils vont donner
la possibilité
d'aller là où elle veut
c'est Jérémie
à un moment
les Babyloniens
ils vont dire à Jérémie
tu es libre
d'aller où tu veux
parce que nous avons entendu
tout ce que tu as annoncé
à ce peuple
pendant plusieurs fois
et tu as annoncé
que nous allions faire
ceci et cela
et parce que ton Dieu
avait parlé
tu es libre
d'aller où tu veux
c'était le seul
et c'est assez drôle
parce que
la timidité de Jérémie
elle n'était pas
c'était pas un comédien
là dessus
il était vraiment timide
il n'a pas réussi
à leur répondre
après ils lui ont dit
bon tu te gères
et
c'était un peu difficile
pour Jérémie
et c'était assez difficile
pour Jérémie de parler
et c'est là où nous voyons
l'œuvre de Dieu
qui va faire un moment
que Jérémie doit annoncer
toutes ces choses
malgré le fait
que ça allait contre sa nature
de devoir annoncer
tous ses jugements
papa à sa nature
timide
toutes ces choses
c'était très difficile
pour lui de le faire
mais il l'a fait
il l'a annoncé
et
donc
ces expressions
où Dieu parle de sa colère
on retrouve ces expressions
plusieurs fois
dans le livre d'Ézéchiel
dans le livre d'autres prophètes
mais nous voyons aussi
que Dieu
et c'est ça qui est réconfortant
pour nous
parce qu'au travers
de ces vengeances
de Dieu
au travers de la destruction
de Jérusalem
et même
quand Dieu parle
de son jugement
qui s'abat
sur des nations
sur des villes
on peut penser
à Sodome et Gomorre
à cette première partie
terrestre
avant le déluge
lorsque Dieu
précipite le déluge
nous voyons dans la Bible
plusieurs exemples
où le jugement de Dieu
s'est accompli
après qu'il a annoncé
à cause d'un péché
qu'il n'a plus voulu
laisser impuni
au travers de toutes
ces vengeances
de ces destructions
au travers de ces rappels
de sa colère
sur ces choses
le dessein divin
est de nous amener
à voir plus loin
et voilà pourquoi
nous sommes même encouragés
quand nous allons même lire
la fin d'Ézéchiel
nous voyons au moment
que Dieu parle
de choses encore plus glorieuses
il est en train de parler
de l'établissement
du royaume de Christ
il est en train de parler
de l'église
de la restauration
de toutes choses
pour la gloire de Dieu
dans l'éternité
voilà
Dieu est en train
de punir son peuple
avec un dessein
c'est à dire que
ce que Dieu est en train
de faire à Jérusalem
était nécessaire
pour que les nations
comprennent
qui est ce Dieu
et donc
pour Israël
ils devaient voir plus loin
et c'est la grâce
que Daniel
et Ézéchiel ont eue
de ne pas juste voir
un Dieu tyrannique
de ne pas voir
un Dieu injuste
ils ont vu un Dieu
qui est compatissant
qui est miséricordieux
même lorsque les malheurs
s'abattaient sur Jérusalem
les intercessions
de Daniel
d'Ézéchiel
ils sont en train
de présenter un Dieu
qui est miséricordieux
mais quand ce Dieu
nous parle
de cette vengeance
sur Jérusalem
qu'il emploie
les mots
qu'il est en train
d'employer
là nous sommes en train
de parler
d'un jugement
temporaire
sur Jérusalem
et là nous voyons
même la grâce
de Dieu
c'est que
la plupart
de ces nations
ont eu un jugement
comme celui
d'Israël
et ces nations
ne se sont jamais
relevées de ce jugement
Dieu a détruit
Babylone
et Babylone
ne s'est jamais
relevée de ça
Dieu a détruit
les plus grands empires
assyriens
et autres
ces empires
ne se sont jamais
relevés
de la destruction
que les prophètes
avaient annoncée
ils ont même annoncé
à un moment
qu'on ne rebâtirait
plus jamais rien
sur le site de Babylone
malgré tous les efforts
humains
qu'ils ont voulu faire
on n'a jamais rebâti
sur le site de Babylone
maintenant vous pouvez
aller dans le désert
pour aller observer
ces villes
et toutes ces villes
là quand Dieu
a prononcé le jugement
il a dit
on ne rebâtira
point sur ces villes
mais la miséricorde
de Dieu va faire
un moment
que Dieu permettra
que Jérusalem
soit restaurée
et donc nous voyons
au moment que l'enseignement
que Dieu est en train
de nous donner là-dedans
c'est qu'il est en train
de punir Israël
pour que Israël
c'est-à-dire
dans le mécontentement
qu'il exprime
à cause du péché
il est en train de nous parler
de la vengeance
de Dieu
au travers d'un feu éternel
il est en train de nous parler
du jour ultime
de ténèbres
et de condamnation
et 2 Pierre
2 Pierre 3
verset 8 à 10
certains peuvent penser
que nous sommes en train
de parler de fables
mais lorsque nous lisons
ces jugements
que Dieu annonce
par Ézéchiel
par Ésaïe
par Jérémie
et que nous voyons
que ces jugements
se sont accomplis
exactement comme
il les avait prédits
et même ce
plusieurs siècles avant
nous savons à un moment
que si notre Dieu
a accompli
ce jugement temporaire
quand il nous parle
du jugement final
qui concerne
l'histoire de l'humanité
nous savons qu'il le fera
et voilà ce que Pierre dit
nous rappelle un moment
qui doit aussi nous enseigner
c'est pour ça que pour nous
au travers du jugement
de Jérusalem
nous voyons que Dieu
est en train de vouloir
nous fortifier
nous en tant qu'Église
mais il est aussi en train
d'avertir les nations
2 Pierre 3
verset 8 à 10
mais il est une chose
bien aimée
que vous ne devez pas ignorer
c'est que devant le Seigneur
un jour est comme mille ans
et mille ans sont comme un jour
le Seigneur ne tarde pas
dans l'accomplissement
de la promesse
il ne tarde pas
Dieu a promis
qu'il allait juger
les injustes
un jour
dans un jugement final
il n'est pas en train
de tarder
à un moment
il avait promis
que le jugement
tomberait sur Israël
à cause du fait
qu'ils avaient violé
les lois de l'Alliance
mais sa patience
s'est manifestée
pendant plusieurs siècles
jusqu'à ce qu'on arrive
à l'époque
des équels
où le jugement
s'est accompli
et là aussi
c'est ce qu'il est en train
de dire pour notre monde
il est en train de dire
sa patience
est en train de s'exercer
les hommes
se moquent de lui
les hommes sont même
en train de se dire
un moment
mais où est ce Dieu
qui parle
d'un jour final
d'un jour de jugement
où est ce Dieu
qui pense un moment
qui pourra nous juger
et où certains
se permettent même
de dire qu'ils ne croient
pas en Dieu
parce que même
cette idée de croire
en Dieu
c'est de devoir
accepter l'idée
d'un Dieu
qui juge
pour beaucoup de personnes
si Dieu
était juste un Dieu
qui dit à un moment
aimez-vous les uns
les autres
peace and love
beaucoup aimeraient
l'idée d'un Dieu
mais il n'aime pas
qui se place en juge
qui se place en juste juge
il n'aime pas
l'idée d'un Dieu
qui a promis
qu'il jugerait
mais voilà ce que Pierre
nous dit
donc il nous dit
à un moment
le Seigneur ne tarde pas
dans l'accomplissement
de la promesse
comme quelques-uns
le croient
mais il use de patience
envers vous
ne voulant pas
qu'aucun périsse
mais voulant que tous
arrivent à la repentance
voilà ce qu'il dit
le jour du Seigneur
viendra comme un voleur
en ce jour
les cieux passeront
avec fracas
les éléments embrasés
se dissoudront
et la terre
avec les oeuvres
qu'elle renferme
sera consumée
nous n'avons pas
encore vu ce jour
mais Pierre
est en train de nous parler
de quelque chose
qui va arriver
de façon littérale
il n'est pas en train
de parler
de ne sais pas
comment dire
une figure de style
ou non
il est en train
de nous parler
de choses
qui vont arriver
de façon latérale
il prend même
l'exemple
du déluge
qui a eu lieu avant
pour dire un moment
que tel que vous avez
pu voir le déluge
s'accomplir
vous verrez
ce que je suis en train
de vous dire
et quand Pierre
nous donne cette exhortation
ça nous permet
de comprendre
pourquoi Dieu
permet le jugement
de Jérusalem
et nous le voyons
à partir
toujours dans le verset 8
pourquoi le jugement
de Jérusalem
dans ce troisième point
verset 8
il dit
à cause de cela
ainsi parle le Seigneur
l'éternel
voici
j'en veux à toi
et j'exécuterai
au milieu de toi
mes jugements
sous les yeux
des nations
j'exécuterai
mes jugements
sous les yeux
des nations
les jugements
que Dieu
va exécuter
vis-à-vis
de Jérusalem
allaient être
des jugements
qui allaient être
impressionnants
remarquables
et vous voyez
là nous n'avons
lu qu'une partie
mais ce sont des choses
qui sont très difficiles
quand vous allez lire
Jérémie
que vous lisez même
comment le siège
se passe
on apprend un moment
qu'il y a des femmes
comme c'est la famine
il y a des femmes
qui cachent
le fait qu'elles sont
enceintes
et elles profitent
quand l'enfant est né
elles préparent l'enfant
pour pouvoir manger
ils sont arrivés
à une extrémité
que seules les nations
qui étaient vraiment
punies par Dieu
à cause de leur péché
arrivaient
Jérusalem n'était jamais
arrivé à cette extrémité
mais Dieu permet ça
par rapport
à un but didactique
et donc
ces jugements
allaient être impressionnants
ils allaient être remarquables
pour toutes les nations
aussi bien
qu'elles soient lointaines
ou qu'elles soient proches
ce sont des jugements
qui allaient faire parler
de Jérusalem
ce sont des jugements
et vous voyez
il y a même
certaines nations
il y a même certains
quand
le jugement arrive
si je ne me trompe pas
je crois même
ce sont les babyloniens
qui vont dire à un moment
votre Dieu vous a jugé
c'est votre Dieu
qui a permis
que vous tombiez
des choses comme ça
c'est à dire qu'à un moment
certains vont même
rappeler un moment
ils sont conscients
à un moment que
si ces choses arrivent
c'est parce que
Israël a péché
et ce sera visible
pour les personnes
ce sera clair
que parce que
Israël a péché
ouvertement
aux yeux de toutes les nations
alors Dieu va punir
Israël
ouvertement
aux yeux de toutes les nations
c'est aussi
un enseignement important
pour nous
au niveau de l'église locale
parce qu'aujourd'hui
nous sommes
dans une génération
où nous avons du mal
à accepter
la réprimande
nous avons du mal
à accepter la correction
que ce soit au niveau
du travail
que ce soit la correction
qui vient des parents
la correction
qui vient d'un supérieur
si aujourd'hui
il y a même des personnes
si ton supérieur
t'a dit
tu as mal fait ton travail
c'est que ce supérieur
ne te veut pas du bien
il est en train de détruire
ton estime de soi
beaucoup de choses
aujourd'hui
on est dans une génération
qui ne veut pas de reproches
et certains veulent aussi
une église
où on n'a pas de reproches
mais ce que Dieu
nous enseigne là aussi
c'est que
lorsqu'il y a des péchés publics
au sein de l'église
ils vont aussi demander
des réprimandes publiques
lorsque quelqu'un
pêche ouvertement
devant tous
au niveau de l'église
il ne s'agit pas juste
pour les pasteurs
par peur de l'appeler
à côté
pour lui dire
en catimini
s'il te plaît
là tu aimes
non
il doit aussi être repris
publiquement
si quelqu'un
là je peux parler maintenant
a manifesté
de la colère
de la fureur
d'un point de vue humain
avec un manque de patience
ouvertement
devant tous
alors il devra aussi
se repentir
devant tous
du péché qu'il a fait
c'est ce que Dieu
est en train
d'enseigner aussi
au travers de la situation
de Jérusalem
elle qui était visible
au milieu des nations
elle qui devait porter
la loi de Dieu
mais si
les réprimandes
sont inexistantes
alors
les réprimandes
inexistantes
appellent
un jugement public
nous devons vraiment
être conscients
à un moment
nous en tant que
peuple de Dieu
que la discipline
est importante
dans la vie
de l'église
il y a des personnes
aujourd'hui
qui sont outrées
parce que pour elle
aujourd'hui
ça ne correspond pas
à notre génération
d'entendre parler
d'excommunication
mais si nous respectons
si nous regardons
l'excommunication
selon les principes
bibliques
j'avais connu
une église
où il y avait une soeur
qui avait eu un problème
avec un frère
dans cette église
on avait
des femmes
qui dirigeaient
des assemblées
de maisons
tout ça
donc cette soeur
a eu un problème
avec un frère
elle lui a dit
je t'excommunie
voilà comme ça
c'est sorti comme ça
comme c'est elle
qui avait l'autorité
elle a dit
je t'excommunie
mais ces choses
ne se font pas
comme ça
là encore
lorsque nous regardons
le processus biblique
pour une excommunication
nous voyons
que c'est quelque chose
c'est une décision
qui se prend
qu'en dernier recours
c'est à dire
ça va être après
plusieurs tentatives
d'exhortation
d'appel à la repentance
et lorsqu'on voit
que quelqu'un décide
de s'obstiner
dans le péché
dans lequel il est en train
d'aller, de refuser
de se repentir
et donc d'être
un mauvais exemple
pour l'église
là nous sommes obligés
d'arriver à l'excommunication
mais
nous voyons
que la discipline
est nécessaire
parce que la discipline
permet
que le jugement de Dieu
ne tombe pas
sur l'église
et si le jugement
si l'église
est déjà en train
lorsque le péché
se manifeste
publiquement
au sein de l'église
et qu'il n'est pas repris
sachez que le péché
aussi va se manifester
au sein de la nation
encore plus grandement
l'église est un reflet
aussi
de ce qui se passe
au niveau de la nation
une église
qui pointe
vers la sainteté
une église
qui pointe
vers la sainteté
vers la justice
de Dieu
c'est une église
qui va bénir la nation
pour que la nation
pointe aussi
vers la sainteté
et la justice
de Dieu
une fois
il y a des personnes
qui ont fait des études
des chercheurs
pour voir
la descendance
de deux
c'est dommage
parce que là
je n'ai plus
le nom
de ce frère
donc ils ont vu
il y avait un
qui était
je crois
un athée
convaincu
et il y avait
donc ils avaient vécu
à la même époque
et il y avait
un frère
un pasteur
qui a été un homme
fidèle de Dieu
je crois
dans l'Angleterre
et ils ont étudié
ils ont eu l'occasion
d'étudier
leur descendance
c'est à dire
après sur trois
ou quatre générations
pour voir
qu'est-ce qui
étaient devenus
les trois ou quatre
générations
de ces personnes
et on constatait
par exemple
que pour l'athée
c'est une génération
sur trois ou quatre
générations
ou plus même
sur cinq générations
ça produit
que des personnes
qui ont coûté
à l'état un moment
qui ont été
dans la prostitution
dans beaucoup
de choses difficiles
et lorsqu'on regardait
par exemple
pour cet homme
qui avait été
fidèle à Dieu
on voyait un moment
que dans sa lignée
dans sa descendance
même si tous
ne sont pas restés
chrétiens
Dieu avait béni
pour que sa descendance
soit une bénédiction
pour les nations
on avait des avocats
on avait des chercheurs
on avait même
des prix Nobel
et ce qui était exprimé
c'est que l'église
bénit la nation
l'église bénit la nation
s'il y a une église
où la loi de Dieu
!
où la parole de Dieu
n'est pas honorée
l'église est en train
d'attirer un jugement
sur la nation
mais lorsque la parole de Dieu
est honorée
déjà au sein de l'église
l'église est en train
de bénir la nation
pour que la nation
aussi soit un exemple
et vous pouvez voir
je ne vais pas vous faire
tout un cours là-dessus
mais sur certaines nations
qui ont étudié
les effets du protestantisme
par exemple
quand on regarde
il y a une comparaison
qui est faite
plusieurs siècles après
sur les pays
qui ont évolué
sous le protestantisme
et ceux qui ont évolué
sous le catholicisme
on va remarquer
que même sur un point
de vue économique
il n'y a pas de comparaison
possible
aujourd'hui
on parle des exemples
de la Suède
de la Norvège
du Danemark
mais quand vous y allez
vous allez remarquer
la profondeur
des racines protestantes
comment elles ont affecté
jusqu'à la vie
politique du pays
jusqu'à la façon
dont les députés
dépensent l'argent
et vous pouvez voir
là je ne vous donne pas
l'exemple
mais on va parler
de la France
de l'Italie
de l'Espagne
on peut aussi étudier
on verra
que ce n'est pas la même chose
et même quand on va parler
de la révolution industrielle
la bénédiction
qui est venue
sur l'Angleterre
pour que l'Angleterre
produise la révolution industrielle
ça va être à cause
de l'Église
le réveil
que Dieu apporte
au travers
des frères
ça permet
que la Bible
qui se répand
permet l'instruction
l'instruction
permet la connaissance
et la bénédiction
de la nation
à faire au moment
que l'Angleterre
est allée
sur toutes les nations
dans lesquelles
elle est allée
mais à cause de quoi
de la bénédiction
de l'Église
et donc
pour nous
l'exemple
de ce qui se passe
pour Jérusalem
c'est de comprendre
un moment
que ce que Dieu enseignait
c'est que le péché public
d'Israël
appelait à un jugement public
qui serait vu
de toutes les nations
et
il donne encore
Job 34
verset 26
nous dit un moment
il les frappe
comme des impies
à la face
de tous les regards
ce que Dieu fait
à un moment
c'est que
si nous péchons
ouvertement
et que nous avons
déshonoré
le nom de notre Dieu
par notre péché
Dieu nous frappera
comme des impies
pour montrer aussi
pour donner une leçon
aux impies
que nous
qui étions
nous qui sommes
enfants de Dieu
qui étions censés
donner l'exemple
voilà ce qui nous arrive
lorsque nous péchons
et ce sera public
et le monde verra
et c'est pour ça
que dans ces moments
quand ces choses
nous arrivent
il est très important
pour nous
d'avoir
de toujours être
dans une disposition
d'un coeur humble
si à un moment
je suis puni
par mon péché
parce que j'ai manqué
de maîtrise de soi
alors que depuis des jours
j'annonce l'évangile
à ces personnes
je saurais me repentir
devant ces personnes
pour leur dire
à un moment
que j'ai aussi manqué
de maîtrise de soi
que je n'ai pas
je m'excuse
pour ce que j'ai pu faire
parce que
j'ai déshonoré
le nom de mon Dieu
si nous péchons
publiquement
assurons-nous
que nous sommes
en train
de demander
pardon publiquement
sinon le jugement
de Dieu
aussi sera public
il y a deux
aspects
là-dessus
quand on parle
de ces jugements
publics
qui sont là
sur lesquels
j'aimerais
qu'on vienne
et on finira
avant la conclusion
mais cette publicité
des jugements
permet de servir
à quoi ?
c'est de permettre
de comprendre
l'aggravation
du châtiment
verset 14
je ferai de toi
un désert
un sujet d'opprobre
parmi les nations
qui t'entourent
aux yeux
de tous les passants
c'est quelque chose
qui ne pouvait pas
être invisible
c'est-à-dire
Jérusalem
qui avait été
béni
Jérusalem
qui avait été
une nation
prospère
allait maintenant
être dans une honte
ils allaient être
dans une destruction
eux qui s'étaient
pendant plusieurs siècles
glorifiés
de la main de Dieu
qui les protégeait
aujourd'hui
à cause du péché ouvert
ils ne pourraient pas dire
à un moment
que ces choses
étaient le fruit du hasard
les nations verraient
à un moment
que Jérusalem
ce magnifique
temple
qui avait été
construit par Salomon
était détruit
Jérusalem
qui était une louange
sur la terre
allait maintenant
devenir un exemple
et un objet
des froids
pour les nations
et pourquoi Dieu
faisait ça ?
Il le faisait
pour apprendre aux nations
à craindre
le Dieu d'Israël
afin que
quand ces nations
voient
ce que le Dieu
d'Israël
leur a fait
les nations
comprennent
que le Dieu
d'Israël
est un Dieu
jaloux
c'est un Dieu
qui est jaloux
et c'est un Dieu
qui punit
avec sévérité
le péché
même de ceux
qui sont proches
de lui
la bénédiction
verset 15
il dit un moment
dans d'autres versions
ce qu'il dit
ce sera
une instruction
pour les nations
mais ici
il dit un moment
ce sera un exemple
et un objet
des froids
pour les nations
qui t'entourent
nous voyons
la grâce de Dieu
Jérusalem
aurait dû enseigner
à ses voisins
la crainte de Dieu
par sa piété
par sa vertu
mais elle ne l'a pas fait
et ce que Dieu a fait
c'est qu'il a enseigné
sa crainte aux nations
par la ruine
de Jérusalem
c'est difficile
mais ce que Dieu
est en train de montrer
c'est que c'était
une correction
qui n'était pas
sans espérance
comme je vous ai dit
la plupart de ces nations
quand Dieu a réduit
leur ville en désert
elles ne se sont jamais relevées
mais Dieu va relever
Jérusalem
Dieu va restaurer Jérusalem
et même ce que Dieu
va faire
c'est que nous réalisons
un moment
que parmi ce peuple
tous n'avaient pas
le cœur
qui s'était tourné
contre Dieu
le souci
qu'il y avait
à un moment
et là où Dieu
prononce même
le jugement
c'est qu'à un moment
il y a eu des rois
qui ont
qui représentaient
la nation
et qui ont tellement
péché
qu'à un moment
Dieu a dit
je ne reculerai plus
sur mon jugement
d'ailleurs
je crois que c'est
le petit fils
d'Ézéchias
où Dieu
il a tellement fait du mal
dans Jérusalem
que Dieu va dire
à un moment
cette fois-ci
mon jugement
ça battra
mais nous voyons
quand nous lisons
nous voyons
qu'il y avait
des personnes
comme Jérémie
Ézéchiel
Daniel
et plusieurs autres
et donc nous voyons
que Dieu
avait son peuple
c'est-à-dire que
même là où
il est en train
d'exercer ses jugements
nous voyons au moment
que Dieu a son peuple
il y a un reste
qui est en train
d'honorer le Seigneur
et ce reste
est en train
d'honorer le Seigneur
et ce que Dieu
va faire
pendant que ce reste
honore le Seigneur
c'est que Dieu
va les préserver
de toutes ces choses
c'est-à-dire
tous ces jugements
qui sont en train
de tomber
et qu'ils vont vivre
la faveur de Dieu
va faire un moment
qu'ils seront préservés
de ça
des personnes
comme Ézéchiel
ou Daniel
qui auraient dû les vivre
vont être déportées
à Jérusalem
Jérémie
Dieu va prendre soin
de lui
c'est extraordinaire
de voir un moment
même quand il va être
enfermé
parce que pendant
le temps où il va avoir
l'assaut
Jérémie est enfermé
parce que c'est un prophète
de malheur
mais même là
Dieu va pourvoir
il y a des personnes
qui vont prendre soin
de lui
pour souvent lui donner
de quoi manger
et autre
mais
Jérusalem
n'a pas su enseigner
la crainte de Dieu
alors Dieu
a enseigné sa crainte
par la ruine de Jérusalem
c'est une leçon pour nous
et voilà ce que
Paul nous dit
dans cette conclusion
pour nous aujourd'hui
voici ce que Paul nous dit
nous allons lire
quelques passages
je vais les commenter rapidement
Paul nous dit un moment
quand nous prenons
l'ensemble de ces choses
comment nous devons
comprendre ces choses
quand je lis
ce livre d'Ézéchiel
quand j'écoute
une prédication
comme celle-ci
qui peut être difficile
pour nous
par rapport
à qui notre Dieu est
voici ce que
Paul nous dit
un moment
1 Corinthiens 10
à partir du verset 6
jusqu'à 13
Paul nous dit
or ces choses
sont arrivées
pour nous servir d'exemple
ces choses
sont arrivées
pour nous servir d'exemple
afin que nous n'ayons
pas de mauvais désirs
comme ils en ont eu
ces choses
nous sont arrivées
pour servir d'exemple
pour que nous comprenions
un moment
que nous servons
un Dieu jaloux
nous servons un Dieu
qui est unique
et notre bataille
au quotidien
ce sera de toujours
nous assurer un moment
verset 7
ne devenez point
idolâtre
comme quelques-uns
d'eux
selon qu'il est écrit
le peuple s'assit
pour manger
pour boire
puis se lever
pour se divertir
nous nous livrons
point à l'impudicité
comme quelques-uns
d'eux s'y livrèrent
de sorte qu'il en tomba
23 000 en un seul jour
ne tentons point
le Seigneur
comme le tentèrent
quelques-uns d'eux
qui périrent
par les serpents
ne murmurez point
comme murmurèrent
quelques-uns d'eux
qui périrent
par l'exterminateur
ces choses
leur sont arrivées
pour servir
d'exemple
elles ont été
écrites
pour notre instruction
à nous
qui sommes parvenus
à la fin des siècles
quand la parole
de Dieu nous parle
de la fin des siècles
ça nous parle
de cette période
qui arrive
au moment où
le Seigneur Jésus-Christ
arrive
dès le moment
où le Seigneur Jésus-Christ
arrive
quand vous lisez
la fin des siècles
les derniers jours
nous sommes dans
même si
comme dirait
Pierre
certains n'ont pas
l'impression
que nous sommes
dans les derniers jours
moi je vous dis
que la parole est vraie
elle nous dit
que nous sommes
dans les derniers jours
et donc
Paul nous dit
un moment
travaillons
à garder nos cœurs
contre les mauvais désirs
parce que
ce sont ces mauvais désirs
qui ont précipité
la chute de Jérusalem
gardons nos cœurs
de l'idolâtrie
de nous assurer
un moment
que notre combat
nous ne laissons pas
un péché
en train d'être
une habitude pour nous
il ne faut pas
que notre conscience
soit devenue
émoussée
vis-à-vis
d'un certain péché
de sorte que
maintenant
nous le commettons
et nous le trouvons
naturel
non
il faut que notre cœur
soit toujours
en train de combattre
quel que soit le péché
que nous soyons
en train de le combattre
que nous ne trouvions
pas d'excuses
à un quelconque péché
nous nous livrons
point à l'impudicité
donc toute cette immoralité
dans les yeux
la bouche
les mains
le cœur
l'immoralité sexuelle
nous sommes dans une génération
qui trouve beaucoup d'excuses
pour se plonger
dans ce péché
mais nous nous devons être
ceux qui ne trouvons pas
d'excuses
pour nous plonger
dans ce péché
nous devons combattre
ces choses
ainsi donc
que celui qui croit être
debout
prenne garde
de tomber
aucune tentation
ne vous est survenue
qui n'ait été humaine
et Dieu qui est fidèle
ne permettra pas
que vous soyez tentés
au-delà de vos forces
mais avec la tentation
il préparera aussi
le moyen d'en sortir
afin que vous puissiez
la supporter
et quand je parlais
sur ce dernier point
où je disais
un moment que Dieu
a permis le jugement
de Jérusalem
même Jérusalem
étant proche
et que nous devons
le voir comme une faveur
et que nous devons travailler
parce que nous devons
réaliser que de même
que Dieu avait placé
Jérusalem
pour être une lumière
parmi au milieu
des nations
Dieu nous a placés
au sein des nations
nous croyons
pour être des lumières
je dois être une lumière
pour mon voisinage
sur mon lieu de travail
je dois être une lumière
pour les personnes
qui me croisent
dans la rue
donc ça veut dire
un moment que si
les autorités m'ont dit
que les papiers
on les jette dans une poubelle
mon témoignage
ce sera que
quand je crois des gens
je ne jette pas
le papier par terre
mon témoignage
ce sera
de cette bénédiction
de jeter dans la poubelle
nous devons nous assurer
d'être des lumières
en toutes circonstances
même dans nos familles
parce que souvent
nous avons aussi
cette capacité
à briller dehors
à ne pas briller
à l'intérieur
nous devons être
une lumière
à l'extérieur
pour ceux
que nous rencontrons
à l'extérieur
mais nous devons être
des lumières
pour nos familles
à l'intérieur
et qu'est-ce que
Pierre nous dit
à ce sujet
1 Pierre 4
verset 17 à 19
nous dit
car c'est le moment
où le jugement
va commencer
par la maison de Dieu
et c'est ce que
Dieu fait avec Jérusalem
c'est-à-dire que
Dieu donne
un aperçu du jugement
mais c'est un jugement
temporaire sur Jérusalem
pour que Jérusalem
soit épargnée
parce qu'après
Dieu a restauré Jérusalem
de même que
Dieu nous juge
lorsque nous péchons
Dieu nous punit
il nous redresse
pour notre bien
afin que nous puissions
être avec lui
dans l'éternité
mais si tu n'es pas
corrigé par Dieu
lorsque tu pêches
attention
car c'est le moment
où le jugement
va commencer
par la maison de Dieu
or si c'est par nous
qu'il commence
quelle sera la fin
de ceux qui n'obéissent
pas à l'évangile de Dieu
et si le juste
nous qui sommes justes
si le juste
se sauve avec peine
que deviendront
l'impie
et le pécheur
ainsi que ceux
qui souffrent
selon la volonté de Dieu
remettent leurs âmes
aux fidèles créateurs
en faisant ce qui est bien
et dans ce même sens
le dernier passage
le Seigneur Jésus-Christ
reprenait aussi
cet exemple
aussi là-dessus
Luc 23
26 à 31
comme il l'emmenait
il prit un certain
ciment de sirène
qui revenait des champs
et le chargèrent
de la croix
pour qu'il la porte
derrière Jésus
donc le Seigneur Jésus-Christ
il était suivi
d'une grande multitude
des gens du peuple
et de femmes
qui se frappaient
la poitrine
et se lamentaient
sur lui
Jésus se tourna
vers elle
et dit
fille de Jérusalem
ne pleurez pas
sur moi
mais pleurez
sur vous
et sur vos enfants
car voici
des jours
viendront
où l'on dira
heureuses les stériles
heureuses les entrailles
qui n'ont point
enfanté
et les mamelles
qui n'ont point
allaité
alors
ils se mettront
à dire
aux montagnes
tombez sur nous
et aux collines
couvrez-nous
car s'ils ont fait
ces choses
au bois vert
qu'arrivera-t-il
au bois sec
!
Il y a un moment
qu'il n'y a point
de paix
pour les méchants
tous ceux
qui ne se confient
pas en Dieu
en sa paix
personne ne peut
trouver la paix
en dehors de Christ
il n'y a point
de paix
pour les méchants
pour tous ceux
qui ne suivent pas
les voies
ce que Dieu
a recommandé
dans sa parole
il n'y a point
de paix
et pour ces personnes
de même que Pierre
a parlé de ce jugement
le Seigneur Jésus Christ
dit même
il est en train
de vivre
le Seigneur Jésus Christ
est en train
de vivre
des choses terribles
mais il leur dit
un moment
ne pleurez pas
sur moi
nous pouvons vivre
ces choses
Dieu peut nous juger
Dieu peut nous corriger
et nous avons souvent
l'impression
que Dieu nous corrige
alors qu'il laisse
le non-croyant pécher
mais on ne doit pas
pleurer sur nous
on doit avoir
comme une bénédiction
le fait que Dieu
nous corrige
mais on doit
s'inquiéter
pour le non-croyant
parce que si la justice
de Dieu s'exerce
sur nous
qu'en sera-t-il
de l'impie
et donc nous
nous devons nous assurer
un moment
que quand la justice
de Dieu s'exerce
nous soyons en train
de travailler
à être de plus en plus
conformes à Christ
que nous soyons en train
lorsque la correction
de Dieu s'applique
que nous soyons en train
d'aller dans le sens
dans lequel Dieu
nous a corrigés
ce pourquoi
Dieu nous a corrigés
mais si nous nous entêtons
dans notre péché
ce que la Bible
nous dit à un moment
c'est que si déjà
le juste un moment
est déjà dans cet
dans cet
dans cet endurcissement
qu'en sera-t-il
du non-croyant
dans la nation
est-ce que le Seigneur
Jésus-Christ dit
car si l'on fait
ces choses
au bois vert
qu'arrivera-t-il
au bois sec
si on a jugé
le fils de l'homme
et qu'il a subi
ces choses
qu'en sera-t-il
du jugement éternel
mais il l'a fait
pour nous
et notre espérance
notre espérance
au travers de ça
nous ne devons pas
être découragés
vous ne devez pas
parce que vous avez
pu entendre
si tu es découragé
par rapport à ce que
je viens de dire
sur tous tes équeles
c'est que tu n'as pas
compris
au contraire
nous voyons
une grande espérance
nous voyons un Dieu
un Dieu qui est bon
au travers des siècles
un Dieu qui est riche
dans sa bonté
et un Père
qui ne nous punit pas
à la hauteur
de ce que nous méritons
il a dit à un moment
je ferai de Jérusalem
un désert
mais c'est le même
qui a restauré Jérusalem
c'est le même
qui a permis
que les Hébreux
puissent rentrer
sur la terre
de Jérusalem
plus tard
parce qu'il est un Dieu
qui ne punit
pas au-delà
de ce que nous méritons
il l'a fait aussi
au travers de Christ
Christ a subi
tout ce que Christ a subi
aucun de nous
ne pourra jamais
en souffrir
à la même peine
que Christ
mais Christ l'a fait
pour nous
pour que nous ne subissions pas
la peine de notre péché
à la hauteur
de ce que nous méritons
et donc nous devons avoir
beaucoup d'espoir
et beaucoup d'encouragements
sur le Dieu merveilleux
que nous servons
pour nous
on